- Quelques fleurs et
du recueillement. En apprenant
la mort de l'homme d'État
dont une majorité de Français
se sentaient proches,
ils sont venus lui dire adieu.
OMAR KERKOUDI
- C'est pire qu'un de
la famille, c'est... c'est...
je veux dire un ami...
je l'aimais beaucoup.
Ça me fait de la peine
parce que je le voyais souvent.
- Omar a connu Jacques Chirac
alors qu'il briguait la mairie
de Paris, un poste qu'il a
occupé pendant près de 20 ans.
Il montre le cadre qui orne
le mur de son séjour retraçant
chacune de leurs rencontres.
Celui que l'on surnommait
le bulldozer à ses débuts
s'est imposé sur la scène
politique française
pendant un demi-siècle.
Protégé de Pompidou
et de Gaulle, il a été
ministre et premier ministre.
Après deux échecs consécutifs,
il réalise enfin le rêve d'être
élu président de la République
en 1995. Il restera à la tête
de l'État pendant 12 ans.
L'un de ses premiers gestes :
il proclame pour la première
fois la responsabilité de
la France dans la déportation
et l'extermination des juifs.
"La France a accompli
l'irréparable", a-t-il dit.
Le président Chirac, c'est
aussi celui qui a dit non
aux ambitions de guerre en Irak
du président George W. Bush,
tout comme le Canada,
d'ailleurs.
- L'Irak ne représente pas
aujourd'hui une menace immédiate
telle qu'elle justifie
une guerre immédiate.
- La fin de sa carrière
politique a été noircie
par ses déboires judiciaires.
Privé de l'immunité que
la présidence lui conférait,
Jacques Chirac est accusé
et reconnu coupable en 2011
d'abus de confiance,
de détournements de fonds
publics et de prise illégale
d'intérêts. Il sera condamné à
deux ans de prison avec sursis.
♪ (La Marseillaise) ♪
En lui rendant hommage
en soirée, le président de
la République, Emmanuel Macron,
a salué l'humaniste.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- Le président Chirac incarna
une certaine idée de la France.
Une France dont il a constamment
veillé à l'unité, à la cohésion
et qu'il a protégée
courageusement contre
les extrêmes et la haine.
- Sur le plateau de France 2,
l'ancien premier ministre
Alain Juppé, qui a accompagné
Jacques Chirac pendant
plusieurs décennies,
a salué, ému, son ami.
ALAIN JUPPÉ, ancien
premier ministre de la France
- Ce soir, j'ai de la peine.
Beaucoup de peine.
Jacques Chirac était...
je ne sais pas
trouver les mots...
plus qu'un ami.
- Lors de sa dernière apparition
en 2014, Jacques Chirac
était visiblement diminué par
la maladie. Le jeune loup avait
cédé la place au vieux lion.
Ce soir, l'Élysée a ouvert
ses portes aux Français
qui souhaitaient offrir
leurs condoléances.
Une journée de deuil national
se tiendra lundi et une messe
solennelle sera célébrée à
l'église Saint-Sulpice de Paris.
Ici Marie-Eve Bédard, Radio-Canada, Paris